so i want to talk about the seven
benefits of nutritional
yeast okay now first of all there's some
myths about nutritional yeast
one is that if you actually consume
nutritional yeast
you're gonna end up with a yeast
infection that's not going to happen
it is true that some people may have an
allergy to yeast okay
in which case they want to avoid it the
other myth relates to nutritional yeast
being
a version of msg or monosodium glutamate
that is absolutely not true the other
point i want to bring up about
nutritional yeast is that
a lot of times when you buy it it's
enriched with synthetic b
vitamins i would not recommend any
nutritional yeast that is enriched or
fortified because they fortify it with
synthetics
and if you want more information about
an unfortified version i put a link down
below
you can check it out all right number
one let's talk about the b vitamins
there's a lot of benefits by taking the
b vitamins especially in their natural
form
b1 decreases stress it increases energy
b2 and b3 is good for the skin it's good
for digestion
it's good for your hair your nails b6 is
essential
for your your mitochondria to make
energy the list goes on and on and on
but mainly when you take the b vitamins
you're going to have less stress
and more energy and one last point about
the b vitamins
normally nutritional yeast does not
contain b12
okay b12 is very very important to
fortify your blood
to help with energy metabolism
and many other things so to
differentiate between natural and
synthetic you want to make sure
this b12 is in the form of
methylcobolamine
not cyanocobolamine okay just make
mental known of that
all right let's go to number two
minerals so there's potassium
there's magnesium there's calcium
there's all sorts of minerals
that will actually help you in various
ways number three
trace minerals chromium selenium
zinc and one of the purposes of trace
minerals is to help as a cofactor
in enzymes and enzymes do the work of
the body so
trace minerals are good for hair nails
skin
muscle anything with protein okay number
four
amino acids there's actually a complete
profile of amino acids in nutritional
yeast
in fact by weight amino acids make up
50 of nutritional yeast that's actually
more than a lot of protein sources out
there
all right number five fiber which can
then feed your microbes which then can
make something called butyric acid
which will then decrease insulin
resistance and decrease your insulin and
help you with your blood sugars
all right number six glutathione which
is a very powerful antioxidant
so it helps prevent oxidation in
different parts of the body your body
actually can make it
or you can get it from certain foods so
this actually helps in
neutralizing free radical damage all
right and lastly beta glucan which is
not only good
to help regulate cholesterol but it's
really good for your immune system
and protecting you against viruses and
bacteria
all right guys those are the benefits
and also realize when you're doing the
keto plan
i always recommend nutritional yeast as
a really good source of your
b vitamins all right thanks for watching
hey i just wanted to mention something
real quick a lot of you have
questions about all sorts of things in
the body
chances are i have a video on that
already
so what i did is i created a document
based on categories
and you can click the link down below to
get this document
so it'll help you find and understand
the specific information that you're
looking for
i think i have over 3 500 videos so
click the link down below so if you need
it it's there for you